c'est non non a mis sa soeur bonjour
depuis le 24 septembre
la chasse était ouvert à paris pour tous
les vestiaires sauf le lierre et le
présent et maintenant tu le 8 octobre
on a même le droit de but et les lièvres
elle est présente oui c'est vrai des
halles à barbès en passant par l'opéra
de montmartre et belleville en changeant
à châtelet
la chasse est ouverte actuellement dans
les 20 arrondissements de paris et ce
n'est pas une plaisanterie la preuve
monsieur servat vous êtes directeur de
la protection de la nature et à ce titre
vous venez de signer un décret qui est
quand même assez intéressant pour les
parisiens chasseur je lis l'article
premier de ce décret l'ouverture de la
chasse est fixée pour la ville de paris
c'est-à-dire pour la ville de paris
intra muros au 24 septembre 78 8 heures
pour tous les gibiers l'exception du
lièvre et du faisan pour lesquelles
l'ouverture est fixée au 8 octobre 1978
alors c'est quand même formidable moi je
suis content parce que j'ai pas de
bagnole pour aller chasser en banlieue
je vais donc pouvoir chasser le sanglier
à paris oui cela puisque te surprend en
effet en réalité la chasse est ouverte
mais en réalité elle est interdite
la l'ouverture la fixation d'une période
d'ouverture de la chasse permet en fait
deux activités la première celle de
chasser la deuxième celle de pouvoir
commercialiser le gibier qui es tu alors
pour paris la première activité est
certes autorisé mais elle se trouve
aussi en même temps interdites par le
fait que pour des raisons de sécurité
publique
vous connaissez que vous comprenez bien
il n'est pas question qu'on tire le coup
de fusil dans paris si je veux chasser
la bécasse dans paris non il n'ya pas de
bkc nuit hier
deuxième donc je ne pense pas mais il
n'ya par contre quelques oiseaux et
notamment quelques canards sauvages qui
les jours de grand froid ou même en
temps en temps normal se promène le long
de la seine ou même dans les étangs du
bois de boulogne
vous allez être surpris mais chaque
printemps je vois toujours une canne une
canne sauvage qui fait ses petits à
proximité de mon bureau au bout de l'île
de la jatte chaque printemps je vois se
promener une canne sauvage avait ses
trois petits gains de temps mais d'ici
de votre bureau avec un bon flingue les
canards sauvages sur le canal là où cela
scène on peut pas les rater il ya une
règle générale de sécurité qui veut que
l'on ne peut pas tirer à moins de 150
mètres des habitations
ah oui on parie non nécessaire mais
coincé quand il n'y a aucun endroit dans
paris en 1950 finir 2000 doit y en avoir
certainement dans les boîtes un ciel où
le bois de boulogne mais là il revient
toujours propriétaire du bois qui est la
ville le pari de ne pas autoriser la
chasse 147 148-140 950 ha bah ça se
trouve 150 mètres découvert dans paris
mais c'est pas forcément laquelle gibier
mais ici vous venez de temps en temps
ici oui trente ans que la cheville pour
chasser le canard et puis se trouve pas
de canard il n'a pas beaucoup ici parce
qu'il ya un mouvement d'une voiture en
mouvement des personnes qui passent mais
les dégâts dans le calme mais les
sangliers y en a pas réussi des
sangliers
oh je crois pas peut-être mais la borne
d'âge et tout est plein et quand par
miracle on arrive à sortir un sanglier
des buttes chaumont
encore faut-il ne pas le laisser se
sauver
et vous est prévu entre sans billet dans
la boutique là
un coin un sanglier fait chaud comme un
gros cochon à s'ennuyer dans le sens des
retours nous ai trouvés du cinéma là ne
manger que de la chasse à ses confères
du budget il semble y être fait dans
l'ordre
oui je ne m'attarde pas la veille il
faut s'en occuper pour faire le film
[Musique]
aux solitudes amer du chasseur parisien
exilé sur l'asphalté milieu des voitures
la fureur de la ville a même pris son
chien qui gît ratatiner sous une benne à
ordures et chats c'est quoi le lièvre il
y en a peu sur le boulevard débusquer
les pigeons ils ont le poumon du bar
agacé la sarcelle elle est polluée par
l'eau chassez le naturel il revient au
galop
[Musique]
ses pairs
ah ah
[Musique]
art
etonnant non
[Musique]